Rules don't matter in language
learning, at least not the
rules that are taught at school.
I'm going to talk about that because I
just finished reading a book written by
Manfred Spitzer, whom I have mentioned
before, called "The Mind Within the Net"
where he covers how the brain learns,
what happens when we learn, and it's
kind of a very good follow up
to a previous book I read by Manfred
Spitzer in German called "Lernen"
I like Manfred Spitzer.
He's very good at explaining what
happens in our brains when we learn.
But this latest book is particularly
interesting because much of language
instruction is based on teaching rules.
That is largely counterproductive.
Spitzer begins his book with the
example of how babies, or young kids,
learn the past tense of English verbs.
Surprisingly, they first learn some
of the very common irregular verbs
for the simple reason that those verbs
are very common: went, came, et cetera.
And so they learn these and by
learning these, and by hearing other
verbs,
they gradually start to develop
some rules, some patterns for
how the verbs work in English.
And so after learning a few irregular
verbs, because they're the most
frequent, then they become quite good
at learning the sort of regular verbs.
That is where the -ed is added to the verb.
And studies have shown that
adults learn the same way.
And then as they develop this pattern,
because they hear more and more of
these, verbs with the -ed attached them.
So they begin to understand that the
past tense is formed by adding -ed.
Then they start to apply the -ed past
tense to verbs that don't take the -ed.
In other words, other irregular verbs.
So after that initial period where
the very common irregular verbs
are learned, they then go through a
period where they're very good with
the regular verbs that take -ed, and
then subsequently they learn the not
so frequent verbs that don't take -ed.
That is the pattern.
That is the pattern for kids, and
it's the pattern for adult learners.
What does that tell us?
It tells us that it is not
a matter of teaching a rule.
It's a matter of exposure to the language,
allowing the brain to form its own rules.
He again illustrates this point...
Well, first of all, he talks
about the father trying to teach
the child, you know, "This is
how the past tense is formed."
That's unnecessary.
If the father is speaking in a loud
voice and pointing his finger at the
child, the child will only form the the
following pattern: that is, my father
always talks in a loud voice and points
his finger. Or he may deduce another
pattern that all fathers talk in a
loud voice and point their finger.
The rule that matters is how the
language is used, and that is
acquired from interaction with others.
In fact, one of the important things in
childhood is the ability to play, because
play for the child is an opportunity, and
is very important from an evolutionary
perspective, where the child can
make mistakes, interact, experiment
with different things, and start to form
patterns as to, you know, how life works.
Learn to anticipate what's
going to happen in his or her life.
And it's done in an environment
which is relatively safe.
It's not like you take the child out,
you know, for caveman days, hunting where a
mistake can have catastrophic consequences
In play, it's basically a consequence
free opportunity to experiment.
And speaking of experiments,
just to sort of contrast the
sort of rules-based language
production with the sort of naturally evolved
process of correct language production,
Spitzer takes the
example of text-to-speech.
So there was a system of text-to-speech.
The original text to speech was called
something like DECtalk, D-E-C talk.
Where this was used with English,
there was a problem because, in Spanish,
the spelling is very consistent.
For example, Spanish and other languages,
spelling is very consistent. In English,
of course, spelling is notoriously
not consistent. So the solution was to
develop a formula or an algorithm, which
looked at three letters on either side
of the letter that they were trying
to develop a sound for in order to
develop the correct sound for that word.
But even with that rule, the process
was very slow. But as the technology
improved and people developing text-
to-speech were able to access massive
amounts of, you know, corpora, massive
amounts of language, content, audio,
text, audio, text, they found that it
was much faster and more accurate to
allow the computer, without any rule,
without any instruction, to develop its
own patterns, its own rules in order to
produce accurately text-to-speech from
written English.
And that's a bit like what
happens in our brains.
We don't need specific instruction,
we just need to give the brain
enough input in order for the brain
to develop the necessary patterns.
And modeling neural networks has enabled
scientists to prove that unlike what
Chomsky said, where he seemed to
suggest that there isn't enough input
for the brain to develop all the
necessary rules to deal with language.
In fact, it is enough, and they
show how it actually happens.
Leaving aside the fact that
not every language deals with
past tense in the same way.
I mean in in Chinese, the verb
actually doesn't even change form.
And when the child is born, of course
the child can adapt to the patterns of
any language, whether it be the sound
or the structure or how words function
in a sentence. Spitzer says that
initially the potential is limitless.
The capability is very
much limited of the child.
As the child gets better at producing
the language, then the capability
improves and the potential, the
range of sounds, the range of
structures that the child can
deal with, becomes more limited, and
as we get older, then we are less
capable of learning new languages to
essentially native-like proficiency.
But the principle is that it's not
rules that govern how we speak.
So learning the rules, being instructed
in the rules is not going to help us speak.
What we have to do is give our
brains enough input, enough exposure,
enough experience, enough events.
So that the brain can
gradually evolve its own rules.
And these rules are more efficient than
any rules that we attempt to teach.
Spitzer goes into a lot of
detail about the hippocampus and the
cortex, which is kind of beyond my
knowledge base, beyond my pay grade.
But the gist of it is, as I
understand it, and some of you out
there may be more knowledgeable,
that short-term memory, even medium-
term memory events are stored in the
hippocampus, whereas in the cortex, which
surrounds the brain, there's a much
slower process of gradually acquiring
skills, longer-term knowledge, skills,
and language, and so forth and so on.
And that the hippocampus is kind
of the instructor of the cortex by
giving constant events: a new word,
a new sentence, new sounds.
So these things are constantly and
repetitively pushed towards the cortex
and the cortex gradually converts this
into the sort of explicit knowledge, the
ability to do something, as opposed to
our ability to remember specific events.
In fact, we don't retain them
in our hippocampus that long.
The hippocampus has to pass
them along to the cortex.
And so the important thing is to
keep bombarding the hippocampus with
enough events so that it continues
to push these towards the cortex.
I don't want to get into too much
detail about how the synapses work
because I don't fully understand it.
But I think what I can take away from
that is that our effort in language
learning should not be focused on
learning rules, studying rules, the way
traditional language instruction does.
Instead, we should be
allowing words to come in.
Sounds they form, connections
to meaning, to connected
meaning, to synonyms, antonyms.
Different contexts
where we have seen them.
And over time, all of this stuff develops
presumably in our cortex, and we have
a better and better ability to use the
language. But it's not based on rules.
So all the time we spend studying
rules, it may be interesting. Like if
we've had enough—and I've said this
before—if we've had enough experience
with the language and then the grammar
explanation comes along to summarize
something we're already familiar with.
That can be satisfying.
I'm not sure that it moves us
along very much, but it might.
But conversely, if you haven't had
enough experience, enough exposure,
then trying to generalize from a
rule is not going to be that successful,
And that is how we designed LingQ.
And in another video, I'm going to
talk about how LingQ was designed to
deal with this pattern of learning.
Not that I had read Manfred Spitzer's
book at the time, but I just had
observed in my own language learning
the extent to which our brains
can pick up on patterns.
Examples? Yes!
Grammar rules?
No! And that had always been my
experience in learning languages.
Given enough patterns and examples,
gradually my brain got
used to the language.
It turns out that that's right.